humanité à exagérer qu'avec la
mondialisation est entré dans une
civilisation d'excès de gaspillage
d'inefficience et que ça il faut le
changer ça c'est absolument clair je
pense que un des exemples dans
l'aviation de ce qui a été dit par
madame azam c'est effectivement dans le
nom cost
cette manière de faire des vols avec des
marges bénéficiaires tellement petit
au moment où l'aviation est arrêté par
une crise virale dans le monde
les compagnies aériennes s'écroule parce
qu'elles n'ont pas de réserves
financières suffisantes pour faire
quelques mois avec du trafic réduit
donc c'est clair que le modèle
économique est faux mais par contre je
pense pas que ça veut dire que le
principe même de prendre l'avion doit
être supprimée je pense qu'il ya une
chose qu'il faut faire maintenant
impérativement et qui ne coûte pas très
cher et qui permet de remplir le le
fossé qui lie à avec le moment où on
aura des nouveaux carburants des
nouvelles technologies etc
c'est que chaque billet d'avion
comprennent la charge carbone vous et
moi j'étais pas un grand adepte la
compensation carbone autrefois mais
quand j'ai dû le ce qu'on peut en faire
et quand moi personnellement je compose
tous les vols en avion privé et
professionnel et que je vois ou pas cet
argent pour faire des plans solaires
remplaçants des générateurs à kérosène
dans des pays en voie de développement
etc
je me dis que cette compensation carbone
elle fait du bien elle fait quand même
du bien en attendant d'avoir mieux alors
introduisant sa introduisant ce qu'on
peut faire aujourd'hui
plutôt que de dire qu'on ne fait rien et
qu'on doit attendre 2035 2035 on aura
une aviation propre mais faisons déjà
quelque chose maintenant et ayons le
courage de des gis ferrée pour que
l'aviation ne soit plus le seul domaine
où le carbone n'est pas taxé quand on
utilise du kérosène donc soyons concrets
pragmatiques
aujourd'hui ça évitera beaucoup de
problèmes pour le futur
[Musique]